J'ai passé les sept dernières années
à parcourir le monde pour perfectionner mon métier, vous
voyez, je suis en quelque sorte un
inventeur magicien et un chocolatier, alors taisez-vous
et écoutez, non, les rayures qui
l'inversent.
M. Wankara peut dire que vous êtes un homme, un grand
ingénieur.  qu'est-ce que tu fais,
je fais du chocolat, bien sûr, comment l'aimes-
tu, blanc foncé, noisette, absolument
fou, beaucoup de gens sont venus ici pour
vendre du chocolat, ils ont tous été écrasés
par le cartel du chocolat, vous ne pouvez pas ouvrir un
magasin sans vendre du chocolat et  tu
ne peux pas vendre du chocolat sans magasin
pas de rêverie qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
Willie hein hein hein
double hein pantalon sur papier uh-huh j'ai
une idée
je sais que les choses n'ont pas été faciles pour toi,
elles vont s'améliorer tu le promets  Je pense que
tu promets que c'est le vœu le plus solennel qui soit par où
commencer où est-
ce c'est juste cool ce qui se
passe oh c'est un chocolat qui
te fait voler découvrons-le, est-ce que nous
qui sommes pour toujours
verrons ici juste un petit groupe de personnes
définissant les lois de  gravité
mesdames et messieurs de la galerie
Gourmet
je m'appelle Willy Wonka
c'est bien trop bien je suis
presque sûr que j'ai pris environ 150 kilos
au cours des deux dernières semaines vous pourriez changer
son permis de chien changer toute leur vie
toutes les bonnes choses dans ce monde ont commencé
avec un  maman de rêve,
note mes mots, ça va être la
plus grande chocolaterie
jamais vue,
petit homme drôle qui me suit,
je te ferai savoir que je suis un
étranger de taille parfaitement respectable.